Bladesmiths, this
is the strength test.
To test the strength and
durability of your blades,
I'm going to be taking
each of your knives
and chopping into these
butt stocks 10 times.
Tony, you are up first.
You ready?
Get her done.
If there is going to be
a failure on my blade,
it's going to go
at the chop test.
Well, Tony, first
thing, there's
a little bit of deflection
of the edge right here.
But the rest of the blade
held up pretty well.
Well done.
Corey, you're up.
You ready?
- Absolutely.
- All right.
I really don't know
anything about a gun stock.
It's probably not some
kind of like soft pine.
That's probably not going
to be easy on the blade.
Well, Corey, I'm not supposed
to work on your knives.
But I think I put another
thumb groove on this side.
It's rolled completely around.
There's no denying that's
a pretty significant role.
Frank, you're up.
Are you ready.
- Let's do it.
I know I heat treated
that edge correctly.
And the blade is strong.
I'm just hoping that warp,
nothing will happen there.
So Frank, you can see,
it took a little bend.
But the good news is that
your edge held up really well.
Your handle was
very comfortable.
The shape of it was
easy to control.
I could index very easily.
But there's no denying, it
took a pretty significant bend.
I see that bend in my
blade, and it got me nervous,
you know.
All of our blades
suffered damage.
So it's up in the air now.
Anything could happen.
All right, gentlemen,
this is the sharpness test.
I'll be slicing
through these apples.
What I'm looking for is a really
clean cut where we're splitting
apples as opposed to
breaking them or just
pushing them out of the way.
And unlike the strength test,
this test is all about what
your knives do to the apples.
Tony, you're up.
You ready?
- Yes, I am.
All right, so your
edge is very sharp.
Even on the damage here
where it deflected,
I mean you can see the apples,
it went right through them.
And even with that
notch, cut beautifully.
Well done.
- Thank you.
- Really well done.
All right, Corey, you're up.
Are you ready?
We'll see what it can do.
All right.
With all my catastrophic
edge deflection,
there is just no chance it's
going to be able to perform.
All right, so the apple kind
of tells the tale right there.
You can see that dip in
the apple, what happened
is it just skated the blade
up and out of the way.
With so much edge damage,
it's just not a cutter.
Frank, you're up.
Are you ready?
- Yes, sir.
- All right.
So, Frank, your blade is plenty
sharp and actually cuts fine.
The problem is that warp.
With the warp in that
blade as it moves across,
it just starts pulling up.
And once it starts
changing direction,
it just flies up
out of those apples.
I mean you can actually see
this big curve up in the cuts.
But it's sharp.
It's still a cutter.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths.
The judges have made
their final decision.
The Bladesmith leaving
the forge is Corey.
Your blade did not make the cut.
Well, Corey, although
Frank's blade did take a bend,
yours took unfortunately
a catastrophic
and irreparable edge failure.
And it's for that reason
we have to let you go.